aliens Vader creepy witches and
spider-man 2016 has been a great year
for movies with so many to choose from
for best of the year but not everything
in the movie universe has been worth
praising 999 so much 9 it's almost 10
here's our list of the 10 worst films of
2016 9 lives okay some Hollywood exec
walks into a room and said I want Kevin
Spacey to play a live-action talking cat
named mr. fuzzy pants and no one in that
room told him no wait a minute I'm a cat
she had this movie made a switch for the
days of Tim Allen pretending to be a dog
the frightening part of this film is
that it was profitable so it's possible
that the same exact could say I want 10
lives next year don't you dare boo a
madea Halloween this is tyler perry's
ninth Madea movie someday Tyler Perry's
gonna hit it out of park of critics
everywhere but today is not that day
unless you really amped to watch a large
middle-aged man and drag dance to Tyga I
would probably steer clear of this one
yoga hosers the film falls to teenage
yoga enthusiasts played by Harley Quinn
Smith and lily-rose Depp as they take on
Canadian Nazis who are actually sausages
nah-ah-ah yoga hosers is simply
unwatchable it's a weed induce fever
dream of things 12 year olds find funny
smash into a very unfunny film if
anything it's a constant reminder that
not every idea you come up with while
you're high is something you should
follow through with this is a new low
for Kevin Smith and we want an apology
sorry booth that Warcraft here we go
again another video game adaptation from
Hollywood when it was first announced
that there would be a live-action
adaptation of Warcraft we all pop back
to the awesome Lich King trailer
yeah right on wait Oh God
what is this Oh baby too huh okay stop
that please Alice through the
looking-glass due to the overwhelming
international box office success of its
predecessor we were forced to sit
through another round of looking at
Johnny Depp's nightmarish makeup on
screen for over a hundred minutes the
saddest part of the film is watching a
team of smart creative people working on
a green screen extravaganza for what
they think their audience wants does
this sound a little familiar to anyone
whoa Blair Witch a conventional sequel
to a very unconventional movie this film
does generate a few great scares at
times but it can't overcome its clone
narrative of the original classic we
wonder if Hollywood watch the original
film and thought hey let's make a big
budget set piece of almost every shot in
the original like this and this
we wonder what direction Hollywood will
take Blair Witch 20 ok never mind the
divergent series Allegiant wait there's
another way in these movies how many of
them are there the acting this film is
awful who is directing these kids you
can't tell anyone ok of course
anything you need interest what I need
you to do is find a new career who would
have thought a movie about a futuristic
society featuring flying cars and
visible barriers and attractive young
people could have the entertainment
value of a saltine cracker Suicide Squad
when Suicide Squad was first announced
comic fans unanimously said wait they're
doing that and after it came out they
said the same thing along with the
addition of at least it wasn't as bad as
Batman vs Superman no um no what am I I
rose I sang in a film over bloated with
one-dimensional secondary characters and
a weak narrative it's no doubt that the
critics panned the film regardless of
the score Suicide Squad is pretty fun as
long as you forget about Jared Leto's
dumbass method acting for only five
minutes of screen time really really bad
the do-over at this point when the Happy
Madison logo appears on screen you
should have your expectations set
accordingly Adam Sandler and David Spade
star in this netflix original about two
losers who faked their deaths and get
new identities faked our deaths it's a
comedy that fills a whole lot like the
Kevin Hart and rock film Central
Intelligence minus the fun originality
be damned that I believe if you're into
a couple of middle-aged men trying to
have sex with women in bikinis for an
hour and a half featuring a slew of
wacky misunderstandings the do-over may
be for you if you would rather watch a
less depressed David Spade Tommy boys on
netflix zoolander 2 15 years after the
original film Derek Zoolander returned
to theaters as he has to find out who's
killing pop stars across the globe we're
back zoolander 2 desperately tries to
recycle jokes from the first film in
hopes of getting a laugh but all in all
it's too little too late even Justin
Bieber's death scene wasn't good enough
to get through this terrible film
okay that was awesome while we're at it
let's watch a CSI cut to remember how
Zoolander was dumb and gullible he's
still dumb and gullible here as well
remember how will Ferrell wore a wig
that happens here too it's all your
favorite things about the first film
with new celebrity cameos o- everything
that entertained us in the original cool
sounds dope yeah fresh for more movie
nerdiness plus TV and comics stick with
gamespot universe and if you want to
stay up to date with all of our movie
videos be sure to subscribe to gamespot
universe on YouTube it's gamespot's
permanent home for TV movies and comics
as of January third subscribe now you'll
never miss a video